Okay, so a final checklist.
>> Yes.
>> All right, tests are all passing.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And the error cases?
>> Done.
>> The new onboarding flow?
>> Beautiful.
>> Yes, and
those material design guidelines?
>> Completed.
>> And then perf?
>> Well, performance looks
great on my new phone, but
this older phone
performance is a little.
>> Don't say that word again.
>> What performance?
>> Behold, it is I,
quote Master of Fame, wait a minute.
I've been here before.
>> And now your back.
>> What's he doing here?
>> If you say performance three times,
he'll just magically appear.
>> Ian, Joanna,
what are we doing here at Udacity.
I thought we already had
a course on performance.
>> So we do, and
that's why we actually don't need you.
It was an accident.
The words just kind of
fell out of his mouth.
And we definitely don't need
to you to go through any Apps.
We don't have any-
>> Whoa.
Wait.
What are you talking about?
Do you have a bad performing
application that you need help with?
I knew there was something wrong here.
[LAUGH]
>> Well Cole,
I don't know if you noticed
the performance stuff, but.
Maybe you can help?
>> No, no, no, no, sorry, no thank you.
We don't need your help.
The thing is if we actually
know what we're doing, and
we don't need him to kind of jump in and
help us because we can go
through this ourselves.
>> Joanna, Joanna, nonsense.
I'm here to help.
Why don't we go ahead and
take a look at things.
Open up your application on your phone
and why don't you start by telling me
what you've been seeing in some of the
profiling tools that you've been running
your app in.
>> Well,
we actually haven't run any tools yet.
Performance has been great.
>> Wait, are you joking?
Is he joking?
Seriously?
Are you people punking me?
Are you recording this for
a gag real or something?
What's going on here?
>> Can you just give me a minute?
We haven't tried any tools yet because
we haven't started working on Perf yet.
>> Madam, you insult me.
Performance isn't something
you just idly cast about and
handle at the end of your application.
When you submit your
app to the play store.
Users give negative feedback on it,
three times
more active than any other thing in your
application that they actually hate.
That alone means that performance
isn't something that you cast
off until the end.
You bring it up to the front,
you should be doing it the whole way.
>> Okay, take a breath.
Are you breathing?
Don't you to fall.
That would be a terrible shame.
So what we're actually
trying to get at here,
is that we have all of these difference
perf tools that are available to help us
see a bunch of different problems.
And kind of walk us through
where maybe there's some issues.
>> Right, there's like trace.
>> Exactly, just like trace.
>> Yeah, and we actually have a whole
federation of applications you can
also run on your application-
>> Okay.
Okay.
Thank you for jumping in.
Your knowledge is valuable.
I was talking.
What we're trying to say here is
there's more than just trace view.
It doesn't end there.
We actually have a different tool for
a bunch of different situations.
Maybe you want to look at
your rendering perf, right?
>> [COUGH] Overdraw tool.
>> Mm-hm.
Or maybe you want to see how
your memory's being used.
>> [COUGH] Memory allocator.
>> The point is that you
have a different tool for
different situations and you can
actually use several tools together to
narrow down where the real
problems are happening so
you can focus your efforts on fixing the
real problem as opposed to maybe hiding.
>> Which, by the way,
we talk about in great deal in our
Android Performance Course here at
Udacity you can click on
in the instructor notes.
>> I know, I know.
You made a course.
We all know.
We got the tweet.
>> Yeah, I saw the tweet.
So, Cole, we really should be testing
the performance before we ship.
>> Oh, yeah, absolutely.
Some of the best engineers I've ever
worked with in my career have all been
performance minded.
In fact, some of the greatest companies
we have out there will actually create
unit tests entirely
focused on performance.
So that they can actually find any
performance regressions that occur
to the line of code that's
checked into their source tree.
There's some really exciting stuff
going on right now out there.
>> It's so exciting,
just like your mad scientist
lunch that you have every month.
>> Hey, hey,
that's a little below the belt.
What is your problem.
I am here to help.
You guys summoned me here to
solve your problem that you have
in performance on your application.
>> I'm going to step out and
get some water.
You guys chat.
>> And all you've done is
give me grief about this.
What's going on?
>> Because I didn't summon you.
You jumped in because you heard there
were performance and you care a lot,
except maybe some people want to do
their own perf work and don't want you
doing it for them, because believe it or
not, I know about Android performance.
And I'm good at Android performance, and
I'm good enough to teach other
people about it, so let me.
>> Okay, so you think you
know what you're doing, huh?
>> I do, I do,
>> Prove it.
>> I will.
I'm being summoned.
This isn't over.
[SOUND]
>> Okay, so now that he's gone,
I'll actually walk you
through the tools, and
you can see what we're talking about
without him interrupting again.